[Music]
coming up on fyi we have a special
report on an experiment that brings
together young people from both sides of
the conflict
[Music]
hi there welcome to fyi we've got a
special report coming up but first have
you seen this
ed sheeran released a new song with a
ukrainian pop band called anti-tiller
they had given up music to fight in the
war the video features the band in their
army uniform and a dancer in one of
cave's bombed out theaters
i found out that there are more than 40
wars or conflicts going on in the world
right now it makes you wonder if peace
ever stands a chance
check this out this is the latest
footage of tension between israelis and
palestinians in the past couple of weeks
there's been bombings attacks and
protests
but this has been going on for decades
but what if young israelis and
palestinians decided to meet and talk
about living together in peace that's
exactly what happened for a special
edition of conversation where us kids
have a big conversation on the big
issues
[Music]
the 75 years israelis and palestinians
have been fighting over one thing
[Music]
both sides claim the same part of the
world is their rightful homeland
it was 2021 when the first time in my
life i saw on tv just how serious
tensions can be
fighting escalated between the two sides
when i saw this on the news probably
like you i was really confused as to why
the two sides were bombing each other
an internet search tells you that this
part of the middle east wasn't always
called israel
until 1948 it was known as palestine
home to the holy city of jerusalem
which is so important to three major
religions that for centuries christians
muslims and jews fought for control of
the region
but after the end of world war ii during
which six million jews were killed
britain and its allies decided to give
jewish people a country to call their
own
within palestine
and they named it
israel
as the refugees boarded the ships that
would take them to their new country
they no longer feared the journey they
knew that the reception waiting them at
the end of the voyage would be their own
people welcoming them with open arms to
the shores of the brand new state of
israel
palestinian arabs who lived there and
neighboring arab countries felt this was
unfair and this led to one of the
longest conflicts in history
over time many palestinians have lost
their land and
homes the movement of millions of
palestinians is controlled by security
walls like this one it stretches 400
miles around parts of an area called the
west bank
palestinians describe life here as an
open prison
israel says the security walls are
necessary to protect its citizens from
attacks by palestinians
but why can't they live in peace
together
i've traveled to israel to meet two
teenagers who who've only ever known
conflict
ibrahim is palestinian and lives near
bethlehem in the waldorf area of the
west bank
talia is israeli and lives in the city
of tel aviv
but in this conversation i'm not just
here to learn more about the conflict
ibrahim and talia have agreed to meet
each other
to get a better understanding of their
lives
on both sides of the wall
[Music]
it's my first day in israel and my
immediate thoughts are this doesn't feel
like a conflict zone
i'm hanging out with talia in tel aviv
it's a chance to get better insight into
the views and lives of young israelis
a year ago tarly and her family took
part in a project run by a charity
called the parent circle family forum
which brings together palestinian and
israeli families to get a better
understanding of each other
this is the sticker that it's the
israeli-palestinian forum
and it says it won't stop until we talk
i've seen people read it when i hold it
like this on the bus
but it's a powerful message
you're tuning
it was during this meeting talia formed
a friendship with a palestinian called
ibrahim a year on they've agreed to me
again
what was your
feelings about coming here were you
nervous
i was sort of nervous at first with the
whole like conflict and like the
military then you come to tel aviv and
if i didn't know anything about the
conflict you know i wouldn't know that
anything was going on
[Music]
now
[Music]
and then with the left hand when you
play this
then the left hand comes in
the closest the violence came to talia's
family was when her grandfather and army
commander was killed
the west bank where talia's palestinian
friend ibrahim lives and the security
wall that surrounds it is far away 47
miles away from tel aviv
the barrier has been condemned as legal
in an international court
but israel says it has a right to defend
itself
before the war was built palestinian
bomb attacks were common
now
there are fewer attacks
you can't really feel the conflict
[Applause]
and the main reason why a lot of people
don't necessarily care
enough about it because we don't feel it
as much as they do so is that why you're
so passionate about it you know because
you feel that everybody should care more
about it
it's not okay
i mean the fact that i don't feel it
every day i'm grateful for that
but everyone loses from this conflict
we lose soldiers
they lose people
we lose people
do you think that all israelis would
think the same way as you and kind of
want to meet palestinians no
not necessarily
and every side i don't think everyone's
on board with meeting the other side not
long after meeting talia three israelis
were killed in a palestinian attack in
tel aviv
it's time to head to the west bank to
meet talia's palestinian friend ibrahim
on the other side of the wall we're just
approaching bethlehem in the west bank
but all i know is before we enter we
have to go through a checkpoint
ibrahim lives in an area that is
officially a refugee camp
many palestinians who live here were
forced out their homes by israelis who
took control of their land
[Music]
there are reminders of those who were
killed fighting for that land
everywhere
[Music]
yeah so this is my cousin he died when
he was 14 years old he was on the roof
he
maybe threw some rocks on soldiers and
some jeeps for the israeli occupation
so they they shot him
i can't even
imagine losing your cousin that must
have been so hard for you
[Music]
abraham's cousin is one of hundreds of
children to be killed throwing rocks of
soldiers
the israeli army says while it's
regrettable the children are shot it's
necessary for soldiers to protect their
own lives
so
what's the point of it
the point is that they want to show the
occupation that we are not afraid of you
even if you have guns you're stronger
than us we're still gonna stand here and
defend our land defend our people
[Music]
like many palestinians here ibrahim has
never been allowed beyond the boundaries
of the west bank wall he's never seen
talia's home city tel aviv living behind
a huge 30-foot wall does that have an
impact on your mental health
i think it has an impact on a lot of
people's health
especially kids like vigor and for rocks
i think it's because of the anger
so are you angry
obviously everyone living the way we are
is angry
[Music]
so what do you think would change the
situation if anything would change it at
all
i think
if anything would change this
or do you not think anything
that's a hard question
if you want to change the equation first
of all we should understand that the
others are also human just like us
so we should talk to them and
listen to their opinions know what's the
problem
what's the court all the hatred and
that's
i think
and that's my own opinion not everybody
agree with me but that's what i think is
the solution for it
what ibrahim has just said is very brave
the idea of just meeting with an israeli
does not go down well with many
palestinians
talia and ibrahim are prepared to put
the hurt and anger behind them
they hope their second meeting will
inspire others to stop fighting
for talking
it will take place at a resort next to
the dead sea
this is the safest place in the
palestinian territories for ibrahim and
talia to meet
we need
all of us to
meet the other side only because it's
the natural thing to do when you have a
conflict with
someone
[Music]
we really need to talk right now to know
the needs and
everything about the other side how are
you doing how are you doing it's been so
long since i've seen you last time happy
to see you
guys
[Music]
how's it going i'm great how are you i'm
really thank you i'm good do you want to
go sit yeah let's go okay
i'm really excited
i just love this view yeah it's
beautiful
[Music]
how do people
on your side
get the fact that you're coming here
they don't really understand the fact
that we're not here making a friendship
and hanging out we're talking about the
conflict we're talking about our
problems our needs from the both sides
we are creating a friendship but it's
way more than that because
a lot of israelis don't necessarily
agree with talking to the other side but
i think it's really the only way
war
makes people lose their hopes about
wanting to live a lot of children drop
out of school does that affect an
israeli children
in the same
way that affects palestinians
i'm sure that that
the answer is no
um the war is difficult
and it is very stressful and i think
that the war
makes a lot of people lose hope but
i do think
that israel has the right to defend
itself but
they're not really moving towards peace
which is something that i'm frustrated
about
i do want what's best for my country and
what and what's best for my country i
think is peace
that's the difference between you and me
you want best for your country i want
the best for all humans what do you mean
that you
you want the best for your country what
is your country is the government in it
but when
we will stop attacking each other
and you will have freedom
and we will have freedom
i don't know if we will live together i
don't know if in different countries i
don't mind
i general i don't i don't care
how it's going to be
but i want freedom
all israelis are required to join the
army when they're 18.
talia will be on active duty for two
years
she hopes to be a military teacher how
do you feel about the fact that i'm a
person that you know
and i will be going to the military if
you really want to to be accepted in
like
between the other soldiers you need to
to hate the other side and
i don't feel good about that
it hasn't been easy for me
to
care
about the conflict and to have to go to
the military but i know that i'm not
going to lose myself in that i know
i hope so
i know so i really don't
so guys do you really think that
friendships like yours
will eventually bring about peace
between israelis and palestinians or do
you think you're just being named
i think we're not being because i think
this is the beginning of everything
understanding
that we are
humans before we are
enemies or the other side and i i think
this is the true core of of
of peace
[Music]
it's really hard to say now because it
hasn't been lost lots of times since
we started to understand each other
so
we really hope and
that's it
i think that friendships like ibrahim
and talia won't wholly solve the
conflict but i think it is the first
step to peace it might just be one one
palestinian and one israeli but if
everybody could learn
to even just tolerate each other you
know we wouldn't be here
one thing's for sure if leaders on both
sides are to ever agree on how to share
this ancient and holy land
they need to see a desire for peace
from today's generation
you can get involved in the big
conversations on the big issues like
conflict racism bullying and poverty
head to our webpage to see more
conversations from fyi
see you next time